au Zaïr le président mobutou a
finalement donné un accord de principe
pour une rencontre avec le chef des
rebelles Laurent désir Kabila une
rencontre qui pourrait se tenir en
Afrique du Sud dans les T prochains
jours après des mois de guerre la
situation économique est totalement
dégradée dans ce pays avec nos envoyés
spéciaux isabelle stè et Pascal stelleta
reportage sur le climat actuel à
Kinshasa même sous une puie battante à
l'aube il reste
dehors à Kinshasa on les appelle
des enfants fils et garçons qui ont pour
seu famille la rue et la plupart la
mendicité pour
survivre Robert m est éducateur de rue
les plus petits dont il s'occupe ont à
peine 5
ans ils sont des
MZ sur le boulevard ils ESS de mer
quelque chose auprès de ce qui passe
dans les voitur ils étai venus avec leur
maman ici la maman l' abandonné
d'habitude les adultes pass sans les
regarder ce jour notre présence fait
éclater leur
colère
leselose
mais victime de la misère comme ils sont
10000 dans les rues de Kinshasa ils
vivent en petit groupe recréant ainsi
une solidarité que le monde des adultes
leur
refuse dans leur extrême dénumement
Robert Mballa tente de les convaincre de
ne pas voler et les aide à retrouver un
peu de dignité ne serait-ce qu'avoir la
possibilité de rester
propreonom c'est comment tu t'appelle je
m'appelle F et l'autre comment tu t'pp
je m'appelle
htier pabo d'aide à l'enfance défavorisé
s'occupe d'un millier d'enfants ils
viennent ici le jour se nourrir d'un peu
de farine de maïs se reposer en toute
sécurité et retrouver l'espace de
quelques heures un peu de leur
enfance rien qu'ici 30 nouveaux cas
d'enfants abandonnés par semaine plus de
subventions de l'État plus de salaire
pour les éducateurs les air il faut vous
dire la vérité c'est un pays sinistré à
l'époque on le apporta tout les
un peu de nourriture un peu de vêtements
et on pouvait les scolariser on pouvait
les mettre en apprentissage on pouvait
tout apporter à ces enfants mais
actuellement comme nous n'avons
absolument rien rien du tout depuis plus
d'une année ce que nous apportons à ces
enfants c'est l'amour mais le soir
lorsque le centre pcabo referme ses
portes les enfants retrouvent la rue
pour une nouvelle nuit
blanche